is
like women are we can't undo our biology
and like women aren't attracted to like
we're still attracted to the [ __ ]
trait which isn't necessarily an [ __ ]
to the ability to stand up for yourself
and a lot of guys like are too too nice
they don't have a backbone it's not
really nice it's like they just don't
have a backbone and they don't know how
to stand up for themselves they might be
like
a good quote-unquote good guy but you
don't want a guy that's like not gonna
lead you and not gonna put you in your
place ever 100
that's i always say it comes down to the
dna and the core essence of a man and a
woman you know so i always say whether a
woman is unemployed that runs a fortune
500 company in a at the essence of
things when it really gets down to it
she's going to win a man to lead mm-hmm
and i don't think that changes in
anything in in any standpoint i'm never
going to change my mind on that so when
women are like oh yeah i'm a boss [ __ ]
i'll do this
i just think you haven't met the right
man to kind of put you in to put to put
you in your place basically and kind of
like
let that you trust enough to take the
will to be like okay i respect you i
admire you enough you take the will and
lead you know they might fight against
it and then i don't want that i don't
want this but i think when they're doing
all of that they're testing so when
women are harsh on men i don't complain
when i see women are hard on men and
they're like
talk to them a certain way or this that
the other i don't complain about that
because i think that's what they should
do
to find out if you are you man enough to
lead my man in lead and look after me so
i don't have any problem if you're rude
if you listed that like i won't accept
it personally but i understand why women
do it because they have to test to see
because it comes down to that same thing
are you man enough to come i don't i
don't think so i don't think there's
anything you agreed with i don't think
there's an excuse for being an [ __ ]
today
i didn't say that
about the women yeah the women no i
don't listen it's up to you this is my
thing is people can do whatever they
want yeah there's no excuse it's up to
you how you deal with it when they yeah
that's my point that she could say well
you can do what you want you could be
the biggest idiot you could be the
dumbest [ __ ] on earth
it's up to me if i'm going to accept it
if you're such a [ __ ] that you're going
to let her talk to you like that then
that's your prerogative she
i'm just saying that as if she's
entitled to do it if she can do it and
get away with it it's the man's fault
it's not her fault it's the man's fault
because no one ain't going to talk to me
like i'm a fool you just get put in
place one time or i won't deal with you
and that's that and we move
uh no i still think it's i think it's a
girl's fault if you're being a [ __ ] for
no reason no if the girl's being in the
[ __ ] it's a girl's being a [ __ ] to the
guy i'm talking about yeah like i accept
it that's it that's his don't give me
like yeah but there are some girls i
know what you're talking about there's
some girls some girls that are just
[ __ ] for no reason that's actually a
personality trait not just you can't fix
that that means she's like that
day-to-day personality yeah
people are there's people like that for
no reason it's up to you to entertain
role
a models thing in that department i
think
of knowing what the right guy is and how
to spot them and what to look for
oh my gosh
i agree i
oh my gosh i call my dad actually i tell
him about the guys i'm dating i could
not do that today
no it's not an american thing
you call your dad and talk about the
guys
no most americans don't do that oh
exactly no no
you think that's a policy i'm way too
close with my family thing that's cool
though no but it's actually helped me to
be honest because i'll be like okay like
this this this and this and i'll tell
him and then he'll like i listen to what
he says i just i'm like you can pick my
husband because i don't want to
look at the leg
the last time i didn't listen i ended up
in like a very toxic relationship so i
was like i learned my lesson i was like
i'm going to talk to you about how that
sounds your dad your dad's a man that's
probably got a log is he still are you
dan and your mum's still together mm-hmm
oh come on
i have nine siblings they're like
beautiful
sort of they're somewhere adopted but
yeah okay
you're living the dream over there yeah
yeah no it's
it's good but that's why i like i
genuinely think like father should be
more involved in like hundreds
like i think a lot of like every i swear
to god every time i haven't listened to
my dad or my brother is like i've ended
up in a situation because we know
they know the mind state of a man they
know the mindset of a man as a man you
know the mind state of other men
more than women and there's certain
things that we want only a dad or a
brother will tell you like when i have
female friends i always say i tell them
a lot of things and i say to them i want
you to know everything i know so you
don't miss the tricks and you don't miss
things but sometimes you like don't want
to listen you have to learn the hard way
which we do i mean depends who the role
model is because that's right my dad's
telling me this i'm like why are you
if my male friend is telling me this
is he like why wouldn't you listen to
him because he's just like
on my case like i think he just doesn't
want me to get married at all because
i'm like his baby girl so he's like you
can't talk to anyone that's all you
can't marry you can't marry anyone don't
look in a guy's direction and get so
protective over me like i understand i
think it comes out of a place of like
you don't think if you had like a good
guy interested in you he would be okay
with it no really what about over the
test of time like if they were
consistent
he would probably kill him
he does not play in at all no you don't
no he's too protective i respect but
that's why i always said i didn't want
daughters because i think that's how i
would be i've always said i don't do it
i don't do this because i think that's
i'd be so protected because i know how
men are i'd be i'd
yeah it would be like knocking the door
and bad boys you know they're bad boys
and we'll smith and roman's dick
he'll be like that they could it
couldn't you know it couldn't work
he'd be knocking down the door
of like every guy literally
literally everyone's getting booted into
the um the back room like 50 cent and
then the thieves i'm having all the man
them around there they they're going to
want to come right there kid
so when when do you guys think it
becomes
because on one hand i do like i do think
women should
like have standards right i'm not i'm
not saying women should have no
standards but at what point is it
delusional
when they can't even attain what they
want in the man so say if they want a
really rich man
does the rich man want you though you
need to think about that yeah because
it's a two-way street
so you need to be able to meet his
expectations
so that he can meet yours as well
or
if you have them expectations don't get
mad when he doesn't want you
if he can't
keep up to what he wants
but yeah that's my perspective at least
i have the same same thing i always
thought about what you were saying as
well that women should bring something
to the table when it comes to that if
they're expecting a lot they should be
giving a lot
but i had a conversation with a male
friend a few weeks ago and he mentioned
to me that actually a lot of guys don't
care
about what girls bring to the table if
they're the providers they don't and
they they couldn't care if she works
doesn't work
doesn't drive they don't care i've
always been on the illusion they do
no but i've only learned recently in my
31 years and i feel like the ones
but they care they do care about um
they care about your like body yeah they
care about the way you look they just
care about they don't they don't care
about what we care about because we care
about if a guy drives we care if a guy
has a job like a lot of times like girls
will think that guys evaluate them the
way we evaluate that and so we'll be
like oh i'm funny he wants a girl that's
funny like all right
they don't know
they're like is she is she hot is she
available
does she like me back
it's true men go off the physical men do
you go off the physical but for me
i'd say not like yo what did you say
your guy friend said you don't care if
you like doesn't care what girl is meant
to attain because he's a professional
i'm a provider so i don't care
what they earn or anything like that but
what i do care about is
a work ethic
yeah
that's what i care about epic because if
you're just coming and you just want to
be you just want to there with your hand
out that's not attractive to me but if
you've got a work ethic and i know
you're a grinder you want to get things
done you want to work then i want to
look after you i want to put you in a
position where you have to do less or
nothing at all but if you've got some no
work ethic you're just sitting there you
want to just sit look pretty next to me
what's that going to do for me i want to
see once if the work ethic is the thing
the that side of you where you want to
do for yourself that's attractive a bit
of ambition you know so that you don't
have to be making loads of money you
could be in a doing whatever but you've
got aspirations you want to achieve
things or certain things that's
attractive not if you're laying in bed
till half two and then you won't get up
in gold party and no we're not doing all
of that
do you think most guys care about that
depends what you want yeah i'm not gonna
lie to you if i just wanna smash then
i'm not to care you could you could if
if you're hot and my only instinct is
that i want to
bend you over then
you could be flipping
sleep all day part of your nights
whatever i'll catch you in between you
understand but so now most guys don't
care to be for the most part if you're
hot i've had conversations like this on
my podcast if you're demanding don't
care well and the other thing is girls i
think girls think that guys care about
their money so they'll say things like
oh i'm like the one thing girls will say
is like i'm independent yeah but when i
this is this is just a feeling as a girl
and you tell me as a guy if this is true
i think when a girl is like oh i'm
independent i don't need a man a guy
puts her in the friends with benefits
category because like guys want to be
needed and they want to be like wanted
um
when i hear it i don't really take it
seriously because i think like you think
they're capping yeah
because you know what it is like
the king don't need to say he's the king
the lion don't need to say he's a lion
so the fact that you're declaring this
to me is i just think it's just
something you heard and it sounds cute
like that so i don't take it that's it i
kind of pinch assault that and keep it
moving no i feel like you can be
independent and not
want like not need a man but you can
still want one yeah yeah yeah i'm
independent i provide for myself but i
don't mind a bit more you know i mean
like no no all day long what i'm
referring to is the one that will tell
you and keep announcing it i'm
independent i don't you see what i'm
trying to say that i'd rather you prove
it yeah just show i'll see it you know
like we'll see i'll see that okay
she's independent she does a thing that
that kind of thing rather than that
announcing i don't need a man i do this
i don't need to hear all of that [ __ ] i
thought it was attractive to men
too until recently well i thought men
wanted women that said i'm independent
and i soon realized they don't care
if they want to provide you want to
provide right i like strong women i like
successful women i do like strong
successful women because then to me i
that's more attractive to me like when a
strong successful woman
bends to my will or tells me to take the
steering wheel that's more of a thing
than some will